[Musik]
jürgen willer wie sterbehelfer werden
dabei begleitet in doris warten weil sie
hat schon viel erfahrung für bill villa
ist es erst die zweite sterbebegleitung
was sind das für menschen die lernen
anderen den tod zu bringen davon handelt
diese geschichte
[Musik]
es geht heute nach bern ein patient hat
sich für den freitod entschieden
in seinem heim dafür nicht sterben also
muss eine andere lösung her verbunden
mit einer fahrt in einem vollen zu an
entspannung während der fahrt ist nicht
zu denken wenn sie aufspanne
weil er die personen erklärte sie
schriftlich als krankheitsbild primus
eine erste opfer war trilogie mieten und
tuffstein keine kenntnis mal so sei für
die person jesu jetzt
alles was es für eine freitodbegleitung
braucht ist in diesem koffer und er wird
gut bewacht
das risiko ist unterlagen können mich
stört das natürlich aber das flasche mit
dem gift lenzing konnte noch passieren
damit gestohlen dann hätte ich das
riesenproblem
und dann geht mein sohn oder gespielt
und weiß was es ist
ja
auch sabine schulze lässt sich zur
sterbehilfe rinn ausbilden sie war
leiterin in einem altersheim hat dort
dafür gesorgt dass exit den bewohnern
das sterbe mittel bringen da der tod hat
sabine schulze nie angst eingejagt sie
kämpfte gegen die katholischen
überzeugungen dass allein der herrgott
entscheidet wann ein mensch stirbt im
tagebuch beschrieb sie den ersten
freitod in ihrem heim dass ich einen
wunsch ich will gehen in ausstellungen
aufsehen das war möglich
das ist senior sie das ist vom tisch
ganz fasziniert dass er das so oder so
weiter
sabine schulze macht sich bereit für die
nächste freitodbegleitung sie überlässt
nichts dem zufall
nicht einmal beim schminken und dass man
nicht unbedingt die bafin wird zum teil
in der letzten stunde dem start eines
ganzes anders empfinden hängt also vom
geschmack und geruch her und dem referee
sehr neutral vorbereitet
sabine schulze begleitet sterbe weniger
in graubünden
das gebiet ist ländlich die wege sind
laut schulze hat zeit mit 63 hat sie
sich pensionieren lassen
an ruhestand denkt sie aber nicht sie
will etwas sinnvolles tun auch wenn
nicht alle exit also etwas sinnvolles
erachten
[Musik]
schulze macht neben der
freitodbegleitung derzeit eine zweite
ausbildung als wander leiterin
vieles sei ähnlich sagt sie man gehe
allein auf den weg bisher nicht was
einen erwartet und müssen viel aushalten
der zug nach bern ist voll
der mann der heute in den tod begleitet
wird machte den gleichen weg mit dem
auto
sie zog ich vor dem jährige schreiber
ich glaube dass ihnen vor sich davor
welt und würde ich dann zu wenn sie zu
uns genau richtig vorstellen dass da
sehr viel applaus 7 schwierig zu sagen
auf sterbe helferinnen und helfer muss
verlass sein wenn etwas im zeitplan
schief geht kommt schnell stress auf
dann schwarze reagiert sie zugeschaltet
wurde das wird sich jetzt als kurier für
diesen gehört einfach zur information
es wird sich heute zu gesundheit oder
bildung für passende schluss und ja das
wird sich am 20
dass das land sich sabine schulze
hingegen kommt pünktlich
sie trifft ihren ausbildern martin
krähenbühl ist pensionierter lehrer seit
jahren ist er ein begleiter in den tod
im auftrag von exit heute geht es zu
einem krebskranken mann der täglich von
starken schmerzen geplagt wird und sich
kaum noch bewegen kann
trinken wer mit exit sterben will muss
den becher mit dem sterbe mittel selber
dem mund zu führen
niemand darf dabei hilft sonst wäre es
aktive sterbehilfe und das ist strafbar
schulze und krähenbühl gehen alleine
weiter ihre arbeit zeigen wir nicht zu
privat zu heikel
[Musik]
wenige tage zuvor nahmen die beiden
angehenden sterbehelfer an einem
ausbildungstag teil
ornella ferro leiterin der
freitodbegleitung erklärt wo die
neulinge aufpassen müssen wassermühlen
tochter ruf in der luther sage zu
vorbereitete oralen enorm ist was sie
vorher asse manier amor gekümmert dass
hier sagen thematik vorerst aber nicht
irgendwie nur die letzte mahlzeit oder
alles nur um es sich nur wünscht und es
ist schwer ihm ansieht und lied wie das
ist nicht gut das connect resolution ein
verlangsamen oder com node zu führen
dass sie dann doch noch was die
teilnehmer diesmal lernen wie wirkt das
mittel möglichst schnell die sterbe
helferinnen und helfer stoßen immer
wieder auf ängste und misstrauen das
natrium pentobarbital hat sich einfach
elisa als sicheres mittel möglich
wegsterben und es ist auf eine sich
profi gestellt hat dann haben wir eine
für woche und das hier sicherheit mir
geht trocknet das sich aus wieder
versprach geht es ihr wenn ihr mir
bringen
stirb ich dann wirklich sie fragen mich
sind sie gestorben oder ist schon
erwartet also da kann ganz beruhigt
antworten es ist wirklich wo es nun mit
wieder für woche dass mir kein fall
betraut
bild bilder und warten weiter sind
endlich in bern verspätet aber wo fährt
das tram ab die beiden haben extra den
zug genommen um pünktlich zu sein
und jetzt das
grillen dann verboten heißt es
[Musik]
das modernisieren
darf ich denke ich ist ein ort für sie
dass der sterbewillige jetzt muss auf
sie wartet jetzt ja auch viel teil
rezepturen sind so der fall ist er muss
nur auf der bank
[Musik]
die beiden haben den weg gefunden
von nun an gehen sie ohne uns weiter
[Musik]
drei stunden später tragen die bestatter
den sack in den leichenwagen
aus dem gebäude kommen die beiden exit
mitarbeitenden müde und auf gewählt der
kinostreifen und es ist auf dem momentan
eher hektischen wonach ich mit 60
dezibel liegt ja darin sieht das ganze
freie gezogen ich spüre die sind ja noch
nie gesagt der luft merklich jetzt
vorziehen
märz werden wieder in der kopf ist das
für mich auch zeichnen sich schlaftiefe
schmerzempfinden und der saisonalen
risko markt und der kreislauf verstorben
und schicke sanftes haben diesen weg
seite stehen
richtig sei wünschenswert
[Musik]
im bündnerland ist es nacht geworden
sabine schulze und martin krähenbühl
kommen von der sterbebegleitung zurück
sie sind erschöpft aber zufrieden
alles lief gut der alte kranke mann ist
tot
die begleitung ist für mich wirklich gut
sie fanden aber gemerkt das ist sehr
lang gegangen ist damit einfach gefragt
was ich so speziell wie solange es mit
punkt ist dass sogar an ihr kann das ist
richtig das ist mit dem arzt relativ
lange gang und zwar hätte der
politischen spitze verschiedenes auch
besprochen wurde der person anbelangt
wir sicher sein
für alle ist es neue freunde und
verwandte sind gekommen um den
gebrechlichen mann beim sterben zu
begleiten familien
das ist richtig das ist oft so dass der
sterbewillige person ihre kinder oder
erden nach hinten ist arthur dent
geraune zu ermorden
[Musik]
sabine schulze ist froh jetzt allein zu
sein
einen menschen sterben zu sehen dass
steckt niemand einfach so weg zurück zur
schulung bei exit die neuen freitod
begleiter stellen hier die fragen die in
der praxis auftauchen
wie sollen sie reagieren wenn beim
verabreichen des sterbe mittels etwas
unvorhergesehenes passiert es leicht
dass ich ganz wichtig es hat schon
öfters geht es eine woche hat unerwartet
gold award des hcg das team gebrochen
hat und die personen sind alle stunde
es ist viel es ist nur dass auch sie
dass es dann viel länger gar nicht
gottes paar minuten länger und das ist
ein schock für alle
und es ist ganz wichtig dass er ruhe
bewahrt opel will er hat die erfahrung
gemacht dass angehörige geschockt sind
wenn sie den leichnam sehen umringt von
polizei und amtsarzt die linie sitzt
weil er immer diensten stirbt also neben
höhe der zeit wie trete ich aus auch
wenn triegel inspektions stattfindet aus
der leichnam noch am boden liegt und nur
per gesetz zur linie in der regel eben
nicht einfach aus mir den angehörigen
dass ein mann sitzt also nicht in berlin
und morgen voll stopfen hat das ruhe
gibt es dann also die harte vorbereitung
machen das mochte legal inspektion
behörde dann erklärt viohl gerüstet denn
er sitzt nun außer umgebracht oder
gespielt hat curiger sie reden apparat
lag für nachher wieder als medizin jura
psychologie die sterbehelfer müssten von
allem eine ahnung haben
die ausbildung dauert rund ein jahr
[Musik]
jörg bilde hatte ein inserat gelesen in
dem exit freitod begleiter sucht er hat
sich beworben
das rentnerleben war ihm zu langweilig
[Musik]
auf dem weg nach hause kommt billiger
ein polizeigefängnis in zürich vorbei
sechs jahre lang hat er diese anstalt
geleitet damals wollte er mit allen
mitteln verhindern dass insassen sich
das leben nehmen
es war ein kampf gegen windmühlen
erfreulich zeige dienstag zeigen da
immer wieder den weg wies alle gott
selbst stimme als erfahrungen im
gefängnis sich gedanken macht über
zähler hoch und es macht und ihrem stil
jetzt setzt ebenso wie der abend
passieren aber insasse bücher zeigen
mehr wind in der mitte will wieder gab
nicht auf
er ließ die kajüten betten in den zellen
entfernen vor dem gitter an den fenstern
montierte er panzerglas niemand das war
bill withers fester wille sollte sich
mehr strangulieren können wenn wir das
kranksein sie mit aller kraft versucht
die kranken vom suizid abzuhalten jetzt
schaffen sie bei exit und half beim
suizid wieso machen es jetzt genau
ausgeteilt wurden sowie zwei gefängnisse
klassische rückschluss reaktion vielfach
passiert so viel ich einfach ideal
situation will ihm druckfrisch das
passiert wohl freiwillig muss sterben
damit wieder druck
aber wenn wir das 1 1 machen druck
bestelltätigkeit sterbehelfer damit geht
bild wieder nicht gerade aus ihren fall
dass sie die unmöglich machen zum
begleiter für die person ist das wichtig
ist es mit wikis und die andere werde so
stehen wir fahren also im freundeskreis
divis und habe die ganze familie weiß es
und mehr das land vorläufig für mich
der ausbildungstag ist zu ende
mit ehefrau gabi kann bilder alles
durchgehen was sich tagsüber aufgestaut
hat das zuhause ist ein rückzugsort will
villa ist müde und hungrig es gibt
spaghetti bolognese und einen entschluss
was die sterbebegleitung betrifft so gut
die sache ist und gott
das separate geht doch das haben auch
als ich ich glaube ich bin gott das hat
das verschieben wir fasziniert
auch im sozialen oder helfen ist gut und
schön aber die ehe sollte nicht darunter
leiden sehr schmal wie er beschaffte das
und ich bin auch froh sächsische werk
sehen darunter zürich hat und auf den
ist gott ist immer und daher dachten
einfach den ruhe
ich bin gespannt wie willi dankbar meint
er das nicht so verkaufte ich merkte
dass er es auch wie dass das nicht gut
gehen muss jährlich fertig machen weiter
wirst du mir bitte tisch menschen den
todes becher reichen ihnen beim sterben
zusehen
wie verkraftet bilder dass der tourismus
fenster aufmachen was cdu sah mich noch
eine zeit zurück ziehe einfach moment
aber fahren
das hilft mir und ich hatte also ein
fach studieren will ich auch für kann
mich schöne zurückziehe
dann ist es sehr gut die zahl der
freitodbegleitungen steigt schon wieder
sucht exit per inserat neue bewerber
doch nur wenige trauen sich zu diesen
job zu machen
[Musik]